this with my bag full of crap hi Ellie
Goulding and now we're going to look at
what's in my bag this is a bag I take
around with me to festival two meetings
a studio first of all I've got my box a
bracelet in when I in boxing this is my
collaboration with baby and to raise
awareness for climate change and
protecting the environment I've got my
notepad because you never know when oh
I've got some postcards and why note
that I didn't even know they were there
Antarctica that's a nerd this is when I
just write things down if I see articles
and I see different things that I want
to remember writing things down helps
you remember things I have to always
take snacks because I'm travelling
around the world just so good they can't
be healthy but they are because they
taste that my perfume always carry
passing because I am doing so many
things in the day and wasn't smell good
it's the eco-friendly one but don't let
that put you off it actually smells
incredible all the packaging is cycle
they really care about sustainability
and my god it smells so good
I've got a fan go do this no sunglasses
all the peoples my favorite it's all
pretty bits much the lip stick from my
Mac line pretty cool still going strong
a hydration tablet when I train and when
I fly because you get so dried out and
dehydrated and flight is also I have a
slight mark so a lot of these things
actually feels like because I spend half
my life and planes which is not what I
would ideally like but I have to travel
to do shows
that's really hot we've been looking in
my handbag and if you want to watch more
incredible videos like this then
subscribe to glamour UK
[Music]